(acclamations)
- Ils étaient nombreux
pour les accueillir.
Ces marcheurs sont partis
à pieds de Ripon, en Outaouais,
le 6 septembre.
40 jours et quelques paires
de chaussures plus tard,
ils sont à Québec et
leur message est clair.
PATRICK GRAVEL, organis. Grande
marche pour protect. des forêts
- L'objectif de tout ça,
c'est la protection des aires
protégées au sud du Québec, en
terres publiques; une centaine
d'aires protégées qu'on demande.
Les boisés urbains et
péri-urbains, qui fondent
comme neige au soleil dans un
printemps trop hâtif. On demande
un observatoire des forêts
indépendant.
- Au fil des semaines,
leur cause a rallié des gens
de tous les horizons,
comme cet homme de 80 ans,
qui a aussi fait la marche
de plus de 500 km.
GILLES HOTTE, marcheur, Grande
marche pour protect. des forêts
- Le sujet est très bon,
je veux dire, pour la Terre,
notre Terre nourricière.
- Ou cette femme, venue de
Victoriaville pour la cause.
- Surtout au Sud, on a beaucoup
d'étalements urbains, je pense,
qui empiètent sur le territoire
forestier, aussi agricole.
On a une grande demande donc,
c'est important de protéger
ce territoire-là.
- Plusieurs membres de Nations
Autochtones se sont également
joints au mouvement citoyen.
YVAN BOIVIN, membre
Nation Atikamekw
- Il y a un délogement de la
faune aussi, puis c'est bien
grave. Comme quand je m'en vais
à mon territoire,
malheureusement,
je me sens comme un sans-abri.
MADELEINE SAÏGA, membre
Clan du bison blanc
- C'est un grand plaisir d'être
ici à la fin, comme j'ai marché
10 km avec eux, au début.
Parce que les arbres, c'est le
poumon de la Terre-Maman et on
doit prendre soin de la Terre.
- Des mouvements avaient
d'ailleurs lieu à plusieurs
endroits du Québec pour soutenir
la cause des marcheurs,
comme à Sherbrooke.
CHRISTINE LABRIE, députée de
Sherbrooke, Québec solidaire
- On sent un conflit en
ce moment entre la volonté des
communautés et des citoyens,
même du ministère de
l'Environnement de protéger
certains territoires, et la
volonté du ministère de la
Forêt, de les garder disponibles
pour l'exploitation forestière.
Donc, il y a vraiment
un clivage qui se fait.
- Une rencontre entre
le ministre de l'Environnement
du Québec et les militants
aura lieu mardi. Ces derniers,
rappelons-le, demandent qu'on
protège davantage de forêts
au sud du 49e parallèle.
Ici Colin Côté-Paulette,